und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend innen allen wir
beginnen heute mit einem einblick der
genauso selten ist wie wichtig einem
einblick in das leben im besetzten
südosten der ukraine regionen die
russland in diesem krieg erobert hat
nach langen grausamen kämpfen es sind
orte deren namen wir noch vor einigen
wochen nicht wirklich kannten und die
seitdem die nachrichten bestimmen mario
poljanski
rodung jetzt ein zdf kamerateam mit
reporter wienand wernecke war dort
unterwegs und hat mit den menschen
gesprochen
zwei dinge sind dabei wichtig im kopf zu
haben die region ist nach wie vor alles
andere als stabil russland baut dort
seine stellungen aus berichten britische
geheimdienstler gleichzeitig verstärkt
russland heute wieder seine raketen und
artillerieangriffe auf die ukraine das
heißt aber eben auch unser fernsehteam
konnte dort nicht nach eigenen plänen
reisen sondern nur filmen bewacht und
überwacht vom russischen militär
embedded eingebettet werden solche drei
reisen genannt einerseits werden wir
hier in der nähe des kampf gebietes von
bewaffneten russischen soldaten
beschützt andererseits werden wir auf
schritt und tritt von vertretern des
verteidigungsministeriums aus moskau
begleitet das ahnen auch die menschen
hier in servern jetzt die in den ruinen
leben und natürlich wegen sie deshalb
genau ihre worte
warum soll ich von hier weggehen das ist
meine stadt ich bin hier geboren ich
lebe hier die ukraine war meine heimat
sie war die ukraine aber ich bin ein
russischsprachiger mensch ich lebe und
spreche russisch
kaputte straßen zerstörte brücken
unbewohnbare orte es ist eine reise in
einem gebiet in welchem wochen lang
kämpfe zwischen russland und der ukraine
tobt
distanz in teilen eine ruinenstadt wer
überlebte und blieb hat nun kein wasser
keinen strom und nichts zu essen
russland organisiert hilfe und
präsentiert das unserer kamera wir sind
zusammen steht auf den paketen die
botschaft an die einwohner hier und dann
die welt die zukunft des don was heißt
russland
ob selensky ihr das sagen hat oder putin
ist mir völlig egal es darf nur nicht
weiter diese schreckliche situation
geben es soll jetzt nur ruhig bleiben
doch daran glauben wir viele nicht es
herrscht angst vor der zukunft denn die
ukraine will ihre gebiete zurückerobern
und hat eine gegenoffensive angekündigt
die schweren kämpfe können also
zurückkommen es werden waffen
präsentiert mit denen die ukrainische
armee gekämpft hatte darunter systeme
geliefert vom westen eine art trophäe
und psychologische botschaft an die nato
dass auch diese unterstützung der
ukraine nicht helfen würde
blauer himmel gelbes getreide die
nationalfarben der ukraine aber hier
wird mittlerweile unter russischer
flagge gemäht seit wochen wird weltweit
darüber diskutiert ob getreide und damit
hunger zur kriegswaffe wird weil
absichtlich zu wenig exportiert wurde
russland bestreitet das in diesem
agrarbetrieb im osten rechnet man mit
einer guten ernte
am tag nach der ernte verkaufen wir über
händler in russland und sie verkaufen es
in die türkei nach syrien nach ägypten
und sicher nach algerien aber genau weiß
ich das nicht
[Musik]
die russische hymne in der
stadtverwaltung von milito kohl
ausgegeben werden neue pässe große späße
im schnellverfahren das verfügte
präsident putin und ein russischer pass
ist hier mittlerweile wichtig für die
rente ist das dokument nötig wie soll
ich denn sonst leben ich lebe allein
ohne ehemann mein sohn es im ausland er
lebt in deutschland
im herbst soll es nun ein referendum
geben ob die region um die aufnahme in
die russische föderation bittet ob es
dahin die kämpfe im donbass beendet sind
scheint angesichts der militärischen und
politischen lage zweifelhaft für die
menschen bleiben es also gefährliche
zeiten
und unser reporter wienand wernecke ist
zurück in moskau und wien an das war
eine dreh reise eingebettet mit der
russischen armee welchen zweck verfolgt
russland denn wenn es solche reisen
zulässt und auch organisiert
das ist öffentlichkeitsarbeit im
weitesten sinne oder pr wie auch immer
man es nennen mag es geht darum dass die
russen natürlich merken dass die
ukrainische sicht viel stärker in der
internationalen wahrnehmung stattfindet
dass da viel mehr berichtet wird das
liegt einfach daran weil man auf die
russische seite schwer kommt und da soll
jetzt gegengesteuert werden wieso heißt
oder aus russischer sicht heißt soll
verhindert werden dass ist fake news
über den zustand in der region gebe und
deswegen wolle man ist zeigen wie es
wirklich ist so ist es und das ist ein
probates mittel das gibt es schon länger
das embedded unterwegs gewesen sein kann
ich war auch mit den russischen truppen
in syrien schon zweimal da wird man in
rom geführt man ist betreut man ist auch
nicht wirklich frei in der
berichterstattung aber man bekommt
trotzdem einen einblick in die region
man kann bestimmte dinge sehen man sieht
den grad der zerstörung und das konnte
man glaube ich im beitrag auch sehen wie
schwer die städte und regionen da
gelitten haben also insofern ist das
schon politisch gewollt von russischer
seite dass wir dabei sind und es wurde
übrigens auch in den russischen medien
darüber berichtet aber wir können
trotzdem etwas mitnehmen und das ist
glaube ich wichtig um darstellen zu
können wie es den menschen vor ort geht
aber natürlich trotzdem nicht das was
man als journalist idealerweise möchte
was ist denn das für ein gefühl wie in
hand als reporter mit der armee im
hintergrund aufzutreten wie reagieren
denn die menschen da
ja das ist tatsächlich ungewohnt dass
man immer jemanden neben sich hat der
quasi auch darauf achtet wo man ist und
was man macht auf der anderen seite ist
es natürlich auch so sie passten auch
wirklich auf einen auf aber es ist nicht
so wie journalisten normalerweise
arbeiten und bei den menschen die dort
leben die wir da in den ruinen getroffen
haben merkt man schon dass da eine eine
aufmerksamkeit ist aber weil sie mit
westlichen medien reden das ist ihnen
schon klar dass es ein besonderes ist
und da sind natürlich viele offizielle
vertreter eine gewisse zurückhaltung ist
dabei und trotzdem ist scheint immer mal
durch die die wirklichkeit ist schon zu
sehen für uns journalisten ist es
komisch aber es ist trotzdem glaube ich
der beste weg hin und wieder mal
hinzuschauen was sagt wernicke unserer
partner in moskau herzlichen dank für
diese informationen heute abend
nach deutschland wie hitzig und mitunter
überhitzt die diskussion rund um die
energie krise und deren folgen ist das
sieht man gerade ganz gut an den
interviews die der chef der
bundesnetzagentur in den letzten tagen
gab am donnerstag warnte er vor einer
verdreifachung der gasrechnung heute
warnt er vor panik es gebe anzeichen
dass die preise zumindest nicht weiter
ansteigen
deutschland und die inflation das ist
eine besondere beziehung irgendwo
zwischen gesunder besorgnis nötigen
gegenmaßnahmen und aufkommende panik
andreas weise
es ist einer der angenehmeren termine
für ministerpräsident haseloff die
weinbruderschaft saale-unstrut prämiert
die edelsten tropfen des anbaugebietes
im süden sachsen anhalts doch wirkliche
ablenkung gibt es für die politik
derzeit nicht leben inzwischen in einer
anderen welt und wahrscheinlich
zumindest in teilen auf dauer und die
müssen wir jetzt in den nächsten wochen
ein konzept entgegen stellen was nicht
nur darin einmündet dass man mal einen
tankgutschein bzw 9 euro ticket für
zwölf wochen verteilt das wird das
problem nicht lösen
vorschläge gibt es genug bayerns
ministerpräsident so erfordert einen 365
euro jahresticket und tank rabatt bis in
den winter und spd co-chefin esken
schlägt im zdf-sommerinterview etwas vor
das ampel partner fdp nicht gefallen
dürfte wir werden wenn der haushalt
tatsächlich in der fas nächste jahr im
september und im dezember beraten wird
in erster und zweiter dritter lesung
werden wir sehen ob wir tatsächlich die
möglichkeit haben die ausnahme von der
schuldenbremse einzustellen denn wir
stecken ja mitten in der krise und wir
sehen die folgen diesen beiden dieser
beiden krisen noch gar keinen noch gar
nicht absehen das heißt sollen die denn
ich glaube dass wir die schulden bringen
sie erneut aussetzen müssen besonders
die hohen energiepreise treffen jene mit
wenig einkommen besonders hart und die
waren auch in der korona pandemie oft
schon die leidtragenden und die könnten
auch doppelt betroffen sein weil sie an
der korona pandemie auch schon so war
dass menschen mit einem guten einkommen
auf einem bürojob vielleicht von zuhause
sicher im home office arbeiten konnten
während viele menschen beispielsweise in
der gastronomie bei geringverdienern
mini jobbern ihren arbeitsplatz verloren
haben
inflation dieses wort scheint in
deutschland besondere ängste auszulösen
das hat auch historische gründe die
milliarden scheine von 1923 und die
währungsreform 1948 sind tief ins
kollektive gedächtnis eingebrannt ich
denke das ist diese erfahrung der
hyperinflation 1923
und auch dann natürlich die
währungsreform 1948 sind in das
kulturelle gedächtnis der deutschen
übergegangen weil eben die
währungsstabilität sehr stark mit
politischer stabilität verknüpft wird
politische stabilität gibt es wohl doch
immer mehr hier zu lande fühlen sich von
der politik vergessen
wir müssen jetzt einfach sehen dass das
was der erfolg auch der wirtschaftliche
erfolg der bundesrepublik deutschland
war dass wir nämlich immer gesagt haben
alle sollen in dieser erzählung
vorkommen weiterhin eine gute geschichte
bleibt politik und gesellschaft beide
müssen schnell sehen wie man mit der
inflation umgeht denn sie wird wohl
nicht so bald wieder sinken
basf ist der weltgrößte chemiekonzern
mit einem unfassbar hohen energiebedarf
knapp vier prozent des gesamten
gasbedarfs in deutschland verbraucht
allein die basf und sinisa horvat ist
der betriebsratsvorsitzende herbert
danke dass sie bei uns in guten abend
und plötzlich was passiert denn bei uns
allen in deutschland wenn basf kein
russisches gas mehr bekäme erst mal will
man natürlich alle dass das nicht
passiert aber klar für uns ist es
natürlich eine riesen herausforderung
auch für die ganze bevölkerung für ganz
deutschland
chemie ist ja kein selbstzweck ist ein
grundstoff sind grundstoffe die in unser
ganzes leben reingehen agrar
lebensmittel in die autoindustrie und
das sind die grundstoffe die basf
produziert das heißt die pharmaindustrie
die bekommen die grundstoffe die dann
letztendlich auch in den apotheken
letztendlich land nun die wir brauchen
jetzt endlich auch für unser tägliches
leben bei mir krank sind und das würde
alles im schlimmsten fall wenn das gas
weg bleibt ausfallen mit sicherheit
nicht morgen aber
kurzfristig mittelfristig auf jeden fall
weil die lieferketten in aller regel
kurz sind und das sind die dinge die
systemrelevant sind und das ist im
grunde die folge daraus wie bereitet
sich denn jetzt ihr unternehmen basf bei
dem sie der betriebsratschef sind
konkret vor da muss ja ein plan b geben
in der schublade oder gut im kohle
bereiten sich darauf vor dass wir jetzt
mittel und langfristig natürlich die
transformation vorbereitet dass
natürlich die dinge die man auch vor
russland jetzt auch schon auf dem schirm
hatte und das muss man natürlich viel
schneller machen ansonsten sind die
dinge die jetzt
kurzfristig anstehen dass man jetzt mit
weniger gas zurechtkommen muss da haben
wir jetzt 67 prozent szenario da kommt
man noch gut zurecht
unter 50 prozent da muss man dann mit
weniger gas zurechtkommen band von
massiv drunter geht da wird sehr sehr
schwer also sprich wenn mehr als die
hälfte des gases aus russland ausbleiben
würde was heißt sehr sehr schwer was
heißt das für die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer
für uns bedeutet das also wenn der
standort ludwigshafen
massiv heruntergefahren werden müsste
aufgrund eines gases meeres mehr dann
müssten wir dann jetzt endlich danach
traf warten was wird noch zugeteilt
letztendlich und ich habe sehr betont
wir haben die systemrelevanz die für
mich wie ich dieses chemie ist kein
selbstzweck wir produzieren hier für die
bevölkerung letztendlich auch für die
lösung der zukunft und dann kommt es
auch drauf an was bekommen wir zukünftig
noch an gas russland nicht der einzige
lieferant was das angeht und das sind
die dinge die dann kurzfristig dann nach
oben stehen wie wird das kann monitor
aber haut wissen jetzt die stimmung in
der belegschaft rituell das wirkt alles
so ein bisschen als ob man sich da auch
das prinzip hoffnung verlassen wladimir
putin werde schon nicht so weit gehen
kann denn das sind des ganzen sein er
hat das eine zweischneidige geschichte
im grunde haben wir seit februar damals
schwer über über den köpfen auf der
andere seite produzieren wir sehr sehr
gut wir sind voll ausgelastet weil die
produkte werden ja benötigt wie gesagt
kein selbstzweck und letztendlich die
mitarbeiter gehen jeden tag die firma
machen ihren job hervorragend und krisen
ist die mannschaft immer massiv
zusammengeschweißten funktioniert sehr
gut aber jeder verstehen natürlich
fragen wie geht es morgen weiter was
passiert und da steht auch der
betriebsrat mit dem unternehmen zusammen
informiert auch ständig die belegten
stehen wir gerade genau jetzt gibt es
aktuell in deutschland haben sie
mitbekommen eine diskussion was bei
gasknappheit passiert wäre dann
zurückstehen muss aktuell heißt es
erstmal die industrie auf jeden fall
nicht die privaten haushalte wie ist das
bei basf beschäftigten die jetzt
möglicherweise auch angst um ihr
unternehmen um ihren job haben müssen
gibt es also eine abwägung lieber den
job als ein warmes zuhause
ich bin kein freund von extrem also zum
einen zu sagen jetzt muss man frieren
damit einen job hat ich habe ja betont
gehabt an der stelle
wir haben die systemrelevanz um
letztendlich auch morgen auch noch
einkaufen zu gehen um lebensmittel zu
haben um
pharmaprodukte zu haben um autos kaufen
zu können ist kann ich alles irgendwo
auch zurückstecken kann sagen okay für
das habe ich eine warme eine warme gute
zu hause aber ich glaube wir müssen
viele dinge auf einmal machen wir müssen
auch konzertiert letztendlich auch in
europa letztendlich energy gas müssen
auch in belgien zum beispiel frankreich
oder aber auch in niederlande die
terminals müssen voll ausgelastet werden
das sind punkte die ich auch gemacht
werden müssen dass wir uns auch
gegenseitig auch in europa hilft es gibt
ja auch lösungen die auf dem papier
liegen die müssen noch gemacht werden
dass auch hier an allen terminals
letztendlich auch das gas auch hier
überall europa verteilt wird ist ja
dinge die die die auf dem tisch liegen
ist müssen gemacht werden es mir so
viele viele einzelne dinge gemacht
werden kohle wo es ein grund auch jetzt
auch genutzt werden an der stelle um
auch hier
gaskraftwerke die im moment energie
erzeugen rauszunehmen gas zu sparen aber
auch kohl iran zu bringen um energie
wieder ins netz zu bringen sind viele
viele kleine dinge und ob ich jetzt
friere oder oder oder ein grad
runterdrehen das macht viel aus aber ich
friere deswegen nicht dessen dinge
glaube ich wo jeder irgendwo beitrag
lassen kann auch die chemie mit
sicherheit sorgt sich torwart der
betriebsrats-chef freundin basf dank für
den besuch heute bei uns und jetzt in
der sendung an diesem sonntag in erster
blick auf die nachrichtenübersicht und
wie hast du da
im norden griechenlands ist ein
ukrainisches frachtflugzeug mit mehr als
elf tonnen munition an bord abgestürzt
alle acht besatzungsmitglieder kamen ums
leben der pilot hatte noch
triebwerksprobleme gemeldet die
notlandung aber nicht mehr geschafft die
antonow sollte munition eines serbischen
und rüstungsunternehmens nach
bangladesch transportieren das wurde
offiziell bestätigt an der
unglücksstelle behinderten ständigen
explosionen und beißende dämpfe die
bergung
der ukrainische präsident see lenski hat
zwei schlüsselfiguren seiner
sicherheitsbehörden entlassen den leiter
des staatssicherheitsdienstes und die
generalstaatsanwältin eine entsprechende
anordnung wurde gerade eben auf der
webseite des präsidenten veröffentlicht
eine begründung für diese entlassungen
gibt es noch nicht
die afg in baden württemberg hat eine
neue parteispitze die nachfolge von
alice weidl treten der
bundestagsabgeordnete frohnmeyer und der
landtagsabgeordnete sense an sie wollen
den landesverband einen der tief
gespalten ist zwischen gemäßigt
konservativen und dem völkischen
nationalen lager heftig kritisiert wurde
auf dem parteitag die beobachtung der
afg in baden württemberg durch den
landesverfassungsschutz
frankreichs präsident makro hat zu mehr
wachsamkeit gegenüber antisemitismus
aufgerufen zum achtzigsten jahrestag der
größten massenverhaftung von juden in
frankreich während des zweiten
weltkrieges gedachte auch die
französische premierminister in boren
der opfer
1942 hatten französische polizisten im
auftrag der deutschen nazi besatzer
13.000 juden festgenommen und in
deutsche vernichtungslager deportiert
jahrzehntelang ein tabuthema in
frankreich
die massiven waldbrände in vielen
regionen südeuropas dauern an die
feuerwehren bekommen sie nur in einigen
fällen mühsam unter kontrolle in
frankreich vernichteten die flammen
allein südlich von bordeaux mehr als
10.000 hektar wald heftige winde fachten
die feuer immer wieder an die gluthitze
die die brände begünstigt soll sich in
den kommenden tagen richtung norden
ausbreiten und auch deutschland und
großbritannien
erreichen
zeitenwende der begriff macht auch
gerade eine inflationäre entwicklung
durch und je genauer man aufs detail
guckt desto weniger klar und heroisch
wirkt er plötzlich
beispiel die gasförderung vor unseren
küsten in der nordsee niedersachsens
landesregierung hatte sie noch im
letzten herbst abgelehnt mit verweis auf
die gefahren für die natur im
nationalpark wattenmeer
mittlerweile ist alles anders die selbe
landesregierung in niedersachsen will
jetzt gas in der nordsee fördern mit
verweis auf die ernste versorgungslage
eine zeitenwende nur dass die insulaner
etwa auf borkum die nicht mitgehen und
jetzt gegen die pläne klagen peter kunz
hat sich das vor ort angesehen
anflug auf eine holländische gas
bohrinsel 30 kilometer vor der deutschen
nordseeküste
die niederländer sind spezialisten für
die ausbeutung kleiner küstennahe
gasfelder rettungsinseln in der
energiekrise glaubt der chef der
deutschen ist die holländische regierung
rechnet das lokale gasproduktion von
einer milliarde tonnen eine halbe
million tonnen weniger co2 ausstoß hat
als importiertes flüssiggas in dem wir
unsere produktion elektrifizieren sparen
wir nochmal eine million
fossile energie umwelt und klimaschutz
gehen zusammen das soll die botschaft
sein das bohren auf hoher see kein
drecks geschäft mehr sein muss sieben
kilometer von hier plant die firma wann
die us eine holländische deutsche
plattform eine milliarde tonnen gas pro
jahr soll sie ab 2024 für deutschland
fördern gut ein prozent des bundesweiten
jahresverbrauchs deutschland hat noch 42
milliarden kubikmeter eigene
erdgasreserven das meiste davon im boden
in niedersachsen nordsee gas gefunden
mit solchen gas bohrplattformen kann ein
pfeiler für schnellere
energieunabhängigkeit sein das herz der
operation der kontrollraum für die
bohrköpfe die sitzen auf viereinhalb
kilometern tiefe erklärt der däne am
bohrer joystick mit quer bohrungen
wollen die holländer das gas reservoir
unter dem wattenmeer anzapfen aus
deutschland ist ein vertreter des
niedersächsischen bergamtes mit
eingeflogen die genehmigungsbehörde auf
deutscher seite und ein energieversorger
aus oldenburg ist partner im
grenzüberschreitenden joint venture wir
haben jetzt hier den besonderen charme
dass wir aus einem unserer windparks
eben die energie für die exploration
liefern können und gleichzeitig die
versorgungssicherheit für unsere kunden
auch daraus beziehen ein mögliches
puzzle steinchen für mehr unabhängigkeit
von putin die 60 milliarden kubikmeter
gas die hier vor der küste insgesamt
vermutet werden aber auf der nahen
ferien insel borkum schlagen sie alarm
kein förderturm soll die aus sicht
versperren bockum klagt jetzt mit der
nachbarinsel juist und der deutschen
umwelthilfe in den niederlanden
erdgasförderung ist grundsätzlich ein
schmutziges geschäft wo sehr viele
giftige toxische chemikalien eingesetzt
werden die beherrscht werden müssen und
die bei havarien daneben auch ins meer
fließen dazu kommen die abgase durch
abwicklungen also insgesamt der
produktionsprozess ist ist schwierig
sauber zu halten und natürlich auf
mittlere lange sicht dass wir hier
seismische verwerfung oder sogar
absenkungen des infocus befürchtet der
bürgermeister stemmt sich gegen die
energie zeitenwende die wie eine flut
über die insel kommt das bohrprojekt vor
borkum war letztes jahr noch vom
niedersächsischen landtag niedergestimmt
worden der seinen eigenen beschluss
inzwischen aufgehoben hat deutschland
gibt gas um an gas zu kommen und
verschont dabei auch nicht das eigene
ferienparadies im weltnaturerbe
wattenmeer
und jetzt sportliches am sonntag von
gudula zunächst zur leichtathletik-wm im
us bundestaat trocken da waren vor allem
die läufer gefordert und zwar die ganz
schnellen und die mit der besten
ausdauer finale über 100 meter gold
silber und bronze gehen an die usa
sieger ist fred curly in 9 86 sekunden
deutlich länger brauchten die
marathonläufer hier gab es einen
äthiopischen doppelsieg weltmeister
wurde tamira tola zwei stunden 5 minuten
und 36 sekunden brauchte er für die 42
kilometer
und fast den ganzen tag unterwegs waren
die radfahrer bei der 15 etappe der tour
de france die der belgier jasper
philippsen gewann es ist sein erster
etappensieg bei der tour und das nach
200 kilometern und bei rund 40 grad
hitze die entscheidung fiel im
zielsprint der 24-jährige philips in
gewann vor seinem belgischen landsmann
baut von acht das gelbe trikot behält
jonas wigger gurt aus dänemark weiter im
bergtrikot ist simon geschke aus berlin
gar zu gerne wäre ich mit euch an der
sie in norddeutschland ließe mir
schärferen wind und einige norddeutsche
grobheit um den kopf gehen das ist nicht
von mir das ist von johannes brahms und
das ist auch keine frechheit das ist
pure sehnsucht nach der heimat an der
küste die brahms auch in wien nie
losgelassen hat wie gut wie passend also
dass johannes brahms noch bis ende
august im mittelpunkt des schleswig
holstein musik festivals steht und wie
aufregend dort mitzuerleben was passiert
wenn sich musikerinnen und musiker aus
ganz anderen musikstilen also mit
saxofon hackbrett oder elektro jazz
seiner musik nähern brahms grenzenlos
sofort rallye
elektronische beats
base jump und techno sound
die band jazz rausch spielt brahms
vermischt classic mit big band mit jazz
mit elektro brahms tanzbar brahms mal
anders
[Musik]
weil auch das ist natürlich eine
herausforderung dass man das einbettet
in eine jetzige musik also dass man so
ein bisschen eine zeitschleife
vielleicht hat und sich am ende des
konzerts denkt war konnte ich mir gar
nicht vorstellen aber es ist total geil
gewesen
[Musik]
auch sie spielen was der spätromantiker
johannes brahms vor mehr als 180 jahren
komponiert
24 seiner volkslieder auf ihre alpine
art wie tiroler band franui
also von brahms wird er auch erzählt
dass er in wien von den von den
prostituierten im modell
ungarische meister gelernt hat und so
und vieles davon sie unter dem tisch
gefallen es kommt aber in unserer
zeitung glaube ich wieder zum vorschein
es kommt auch das nicht so schöne das
dreckige wenn man so will kommt auch in
der musik vor in vielen konzerten an
vielen orten präsentiert das schleswig
holstein musik festival einen
umfassenden und neuen blick auf den
norddeutschen komponisten und seiner
wir haben über 200 konzerte davon widmen
wir knapp die hälfte brahms oder brahms
bezüge im programm und wir sind an über
100 verschiedenen spielstätten
gespielt wird natürlich auch brahms im
original
[Musik]
von igor levit
starpianist und brahms sind
große liebe ich spiele seine musik vor
allen dingen dieses zweite
klavierkonzert von ganzen herzen gerne
es erfüllt mich es belebt mich es macht
mich einfach sehr sehr glücklich
romantik trifft
ungewöhnlicher klanggenuss das schleswig
holstein musik festival noch bis ende
august
brahms macht glücklich und was die
kommende woche bringt das zeigt mir
jetzt laura panik hat den heute journal
ausblick
[Musik]
am montag werden sich bundeskanzler
scholz und der ägyptische präsident als
sie in berlin beraten anlass ist der
dreizehnte petersberger klimadialog der
zur vorbereitung des un-klimagipfels in
sharm el-sheikh im herbst dient
deutschland und ägypten werden dieses
jahr die gastgeber sein nach olaf scholz
wird als sie den bundespräsidenten im
schloss bellevue besuchen
am mittwoch wird die eu kommission in
brüssel ihren entwurf eines gas
notfallplans vorstellen damit will man
auf einen möglichen gas mangel im herbst
oder winter vorbereitet sein konkret
soll beispielsweise in öffentlichen
gebäuden und büros weniger geheizt
werden als mögliche obergrenze nennt die
eu-kommission dabei eine temperatur von
19 grad
mit spannung wird donnerstag das ende
der wartungsarbeiten an der pipeline
nord stream 1 erwartet russland hatte
wegen reparaturarbeiten die
gaslieferungen bereits im juni stark
gedrosselt in europa gibt es die sorge
dass russland aus politischen gründen
den gashahn nach ende der aktuellen
wartungsarbeiten an den rohren nicht
wieder aufdrehen könnte
das wetter bringt in dieser juliwoche
also extreme hitze morgen sind es 27 bis
36 grad dazu im süden viel sonne eben
noch in einige wolken im nordosten auch
dichtere wolkenfelder an der küste
frischer wind bei 23 bis 27 grad am
dienstag wird es dann im westen bis zu
40 grad heiß auch sonst liegen die
temperaturen über 30 grad am mittwoch
gewitter am wärmsten wird es dann im
osten
viel dunkelrot gerade zu sehen das war
unser sonntag im heute journal gedanken
dass sie dabei waren um 0.30 meldet sich
christopher wehrmann mit einer heute
express wir sagen es morgen und für
heute vom gesamten team einen angenehmen
abend
[Musik]